I was to take your luck in the cave
yesterday Australia squash couldn't
figure out a lie for me was getting
rather I'm getting new temperatures that
were huge
turns out I am I sensed the Coriolis
parameter went as the cause of last to
draw from the sign of latitude really
simple mistake that was going in the
coding howler Hall of Fame internet Lee
I do actually keep coding how loose Hall
of Fame if you'd like to see me talk
about that next time done comment below
because that is definitely not the worst
thing I've done after that morning of
coding those now it's time for another
swimming date with pixel del Sol no
don't worry you just look like a bunch
of pixels don't worry pixel go
have to find a way of like visually
communicating how we swim
[Music]
oh bloody hell the office is quiet
everyone's gone are all there in Vienna
there's going to come that conference on
this week I could just go away but now
it's just me sir half four and I'm gonna
be here for a bit yet Dutch angle why
not for the record I am wiped I am so so
tired ceiling a mile Atlantis only you
can found that and I'm going to run
tomorrow but I got work to do so I'm
going to do it alright in plastics
I am conceding defeat for today I might
ask you what kind of same to go the
weekend because I feel like it is really
close now and I've said this so many
times before but yeah it's now a problem
with Fortran like I think I know what
I'm doing in terms of physics its coding
it up in the new language that is new to
me that's causing the problems and
fortran's a little bit archaic that's
where our problems of its own still
there good day's work
good weeks work
[Music]
run this morning all right time to the
post runway in first time through a
couple of weeks after that and now it's
time to undo all of that with a really
big corn lunch actually this is
surprisingly not calorific cool corn man
better me and I'm watching my favorite
stream today the good day
so quite a busy day today I've got all I
want to do but let's stop singing the
concert so I have all day to actually do
stuff by myself starting off with touch
of framing long-term views of the
channel might remember that I created a
top female scientist card game which
definitely some Top Trumps because I
don't get in legal trouble with dr. Han
awake for two now works at NASA for
those of you who are new to the channel
I created a card game based on top
female scientists we've got an hatred
and they are like top trans basically
here's an example car that's Claudia
Alexander who actually died since we
made this game very sadly that's Maria
Kurt Meyer who is one of the physicists
in the deck and there are 32 female
scientists in total we got geologists or
paleontologists biologists physicists
mathematicians chemists I think that's
it
and the idea is it's like the top trance
can you compare and might compete if
you'd like to get a set you can actually
print them yourself though it's all
completely free on imager or in girth
having announced it live down there in
the description and if you'd like to use
this as an you're a teacher for example
please do I bring this up because this
is the last physical deck in my
possession we actually got a few hundred
printed and we assembled by hand and I
kept one back because I wanted to frame
the cups
recently I finally took some action on
this and I got one of these big a two
frames from Amazon and actually done
some work on it already which I'll show
you but yeah I wanted to be able to see
displays because we want more for the
deck I think it's pretty cool project
the whole point of it is to raise
awareness because you know when I went
into this the 32 people as I said in the
deck and I only heard of like
five of them these were a bit amazing
things so we actually went ahead and
pre-scored this plaque card these are
the exact dimensions of cards and as
like a regular grid I'm going to say I'm
not a good regular grid I also love this
house though one thing it does lack is a
place to kind of do you world like this
which is why I'm squatting on the living
room floor on our coffee table because
we don't have a big enough desk
otherwise death they didn't just get an
alphabet wrong there so now I just need
to clear these in place like primary
school something that I thought was
interesting if a bit sad was the
reaction we've got putting these online
because on the response in person other
people who have like got their hands on
decks and actually use them in classroom
settings you had any positive feedback
from you creating the project the warm
place that we've had negative feedback
from interestingly was the feminism
subreddit and which you know I realize
it's a broad term that it includes so
many different opinions and everything
like that but I thought it was a little
bit disappointing really in a project
that was exclusively aimed at trying to
promote female scientists which is
desperately needed because like I said
these women did phenomenal things I
didn't know about - scientists yeah the
fact that they didn't seem to like this
was interesting not all of them I like
to point out all of the subreddit the
big problem that people seem to have
with the project was a some people
commenting and updating we shouldn't be
ranking these peoples accomplishments
and like trying to compare them because
that's that's not good for the
Advancement of the cause and like he
played Top Trumps know I'm like Casey
nice stuff but much less money
[Applause]
done well I need to put something in at
the bottom because this mental obviously
I definitely didn't mess up and get
upside down the first time around
yeah I'm pretty shuffle this I don't
like to play favorites hopper but you're
definitely my favorite next I've got a
whole bunch of emails to apply to
incidentally if your email being a ham
reply it's probably not because I hate
you it's because I'm terrible at emails
but it's mean like that so I'm going on
proposal I'm psychic so much it's kind
of interesting crossroads for me at the
moment which I hope is also translating
in something interesting to watch which
is in transitioning from being a
lifelong student and a PhD student and
kind of like a an institutionalized
learner to becoming an independent video
maker and transitioning into my new
career you know and it's almost like
growing up mark
- I'm becoming more in control of things
like my finances because I don't get a
stipend anymore I don't get student loan
anymore and actually sort of having to
think as a business I guess
and yeah so strategizing and planning
and kind of all the stuff I thought be
boring with other kids actually turns
out to be kind of cool and what I'm
doing now is quite a key part of that
transition into being a proper I hope
which is getting a website and sort of
designing what I won I've had a clear
vision of what I want for a while but it
actually turns out to be a little a
little complicated than just taking from
my brain and putting it straight into
the website I'm using Squarespace very
much curious give it to Squarespace I'll
come forward like a real engineering for
I think it's ten percent off your first
purchase and 14 days free it's not my
code it's Brian from real engineering of
code but I'm using it so if you want it
you go ahead you know he's a nice guy
kind of strange feeling though on
yeah like being conscious of I'm
marketing myself as a brand of a product
I kind of weird I don't know how I feel
about this very easily Christ I have
made a lot of videos going through and
adding thumbnails to the website bloody
hell I've forgotten just how many have
made that all available given my back
catalogue you might face then is
actually good oh my days that took so
much longer than I thought it would
I'm such a perfectionist right times me
to do the face but no oh so tired Jesus
times me to do the YouTube because I
honestly made a video this week Facebook
really double in crash course haven't
made a video this week so ever get to
actually get some flog editing done at
my classic editing hours
[Music]
so I've not been feeling much today
because it's been a bit of a dull day to
be honest I did make cakes yeah they're
you understand it so now started editing
again working on the blog which
hopefully the first part will be out
tomorrow I'd really like to get
something out and I need to get back on
soon crash course which as you may
notice is something of a cyclical thing
I have to get quite a few questions
about how I edit and what I use so I
thought it might be interesting to make
this minisode about how it and some tips
that I've learned through many many many
mistakes to answer the obvious questions
those of you who don't recognize that
I'm using the Adobe Creative Cloud using
Premiere to basically everything some
stuff for example like tracking lives
face if I need to do a complicated face
mask I use After Effects and in the beer
mile see called the Bowling for
Columbine I used after effects to put
the text up on screen as done was
talking but mostly I use premiere before
using Premiere I use Sony Vegas for all
of my videos for years and that's a good
cheap lightweight editor that I
recommend to anyone I was using version
11 so you know that's one to check out
if you'd like something that's a little
bit less intimidating than premio which
is so much more powerful but much more
intimidating although I started out
using Windows Movie Maker which is
terrible if it was the point being
though is that you shouldn't wait to get
professional software before we start
editing I think that's the first thing I
wanted to say it's good some editing is
defined by what you produce at the end
of it not by the products you use in
making it obviously is too correlated
but it's very possible to make a
completely you know stunning viral video
with me basic editing software you don't
need premiere because conversely getting
premiere doesn't guarantee really good
video as this channel show further to
that second bit of advice which I kids
when his editing and thinking about
doing YouTube is um to edit never quote
from Spielberg who said that he didn't
become a good director because he
watched lots of films he became a good
director because he made lots of films
and that's true for editing editing is a
tactile skill use your hands and your
brain and in order to get good at it
you've just got to
one of the beds of advice I wish I've
been given earlier in my youtube career
which I got from an amazing Phil I think
is that you've got to accept that your
first 50 videos it can be terrible and
once you accept that and the lessons you
learn from those videos you move on then
you can actually start making something
is good and it's so so true for editing
you know you've got to learn by making
mistakes I could talk about this for a
while actually I can fix Liam Premiere
there's loads of tips and tricks you can
do or there's like more kind of
practical things that I personally do
with anything if you like hearing about
me talking about the practical side of
YouTube like how I shoot videos how to
edit them the metadata side comment
below because I'm very happy to talk
about this stuff I think it's much more
interesting than my life because my life
strawberry shreds - I feel that with
breaking their vlog up into minisodes I
can do this I can specialize them into
become topics without scaring people off
and you know having this content lost in
the middle of an episode so yeah comment
if you like to see more of this now
though it's time to practice what I
preach and get more practice editing
because if I don't you go get a beginner
to watch I wouldn't want to deprive you
so thank you is a channel I met that guy
at VidCon and he sent me his latest
video which I'll link down below because
this was really good man like I actually
learned a few things I mean I've been on
the block of educational videos a few
times I learned a few actually really
cool things in this video so go check
them out it's a new channel he then he
got a hundred or so subs so yeah I think
he was great doesn't sound good man I
just - oh there we go
I've been losing weight as well so
several hours later I've been editing
and I just finished off the first of the
new vlog episodes I'm really really
interested to see people making that
tomorrow and a village for the crash
cross stuff one of our files is missing
that's not good
but generally pretty productive evening
actually and a pretty productive week
sort of to bring up things to a close I
realized at the start of the the week I
said that it was going to be one the big
breakthroughs the PhD and I feel like
actually on reviewing all the stuff
having had to do it I think that we are
actually really close um III have to
sound very down in these videos because
I'm always talking about the caring and
how it's driving me at the wall and I
never quite get it but um I feel like
I'm closing it in it's like
turning an animal into the corner it
could lash out any point and probably
bite my head off but uh I got AI feel
like maybe the animals are a sloth or or
something suitably not not Tiger like so
yeah it's been a good week
I've enjoyed logging again actually lots
of exercise lots of PhD work a little
bit of singing are so much more than
that really you'll be seeing me on the
channel in crash course next week along
with a bunch of vlogs but I haven't
finished editing yet but I will I swear
to go get round to lots of few ideas
that he actually does get in the late
isn't it I can't wait to make so yeah
I'll see you around on the channel do
comment over what you thought of the new
format of this series of vlogs and many
suggestions for you'd like me to talk
about in minisodes in the future and
yeah thanks for watching good night
by travelpod member
[Music]